so
[Music]
be still
go on to bed
nobody know
what lies ahead
and life is sure
[Music]
be still
wild and young
long may your innocence rain
like shells on the shore
and may your limits be unknown
and may your efforts be your own
if you ever fear you can't take it
anymore
don't break
character
you've got a
lot of heart
is this real or just a dream
rise up like the sun
and
labor till the work is done
[Music]
fearlessness on your sleep
when you come back
tell me what did you see
was there something out there for me
be still
close your eyes
[Music]
soon enough you'll be on your own
and straight
and if they drag you through the mud
it doesn't change what's in your blood
don't
break
character
you've got a
lot of heart
is this real or just a dream
[Music]
be still
be still
[Music]
be still
be still
[Music]
over i
[Music]
in your wildest dreams
[Music]
when they knock you down
when they knock you down
don't
character
you've got so
much heart
is this real or just a dream
rise up like the sun
and
labor till the work is done rise up like
the sun
and labor till the work is rise up like
the sun
[Music]
you